the stage set for saturday's home opener
for the las vegas lights
they will face off against the tacoma
defiance at catchment field
christian casarez joining us live there
with how the team is gearing up
for the match hey there christian
hey brian well let me tell you it's
going to be quite a match on saturday
the las vegas lights
are prepared they are ready to get las
vegas a big
win check it out the players are have
been out here for almost about an
hour or so getting ready warming up and
basically
getting that energy in to uh basically
all their plays for this coming saturday
now the players have been
warming out here like i mentioned and
they're getting ready for their opponent
because that opponent is on a good
stretch the tacoma defiance well they've
had three victories one of those was a
tie against
galaxy but that is all going to end on
saturday now out here joining me is also
the owner of the team brett lashbrook
thank you so much for joining me uh and
the question that everyone is asking me
uh also on social media is where's cash
okay
cash you know how performers are right
that'll uh you know cash he's the he's
the greatest
mascot in all professional sports but
he's fixing his hair right now so so
you're stuck with me the good people of
las vegas my cash is uh
tripping himself in the mirror all right
so the big question is
uh how are you feeling and what's it
like
for the team to have all the fans out
here cheering them on
it's it's so exciting right it's been
it's been a hard 20 months since our
last game in front of a full house and
you know the the restrictions are gone
and we are expecting almost a full house
sold out
eight nine ten thousand people coming
down here downtown saturday night
soccer fiesta singing and dancing and
going oleo leolae all right
thank you so much and obviously a big
win here for the las vegas lights on
saturday
7 30 there's still tickets available all
that information on our website
8newsnow.com